[Música]
todos los días desde que empieza la
pandemia del coronavirus decenas de
adultos pasan las tardes elevando
cometas en las favelas de río de janeiro
nadie podía trabajar nadie podía salir
de casa entonces cada uno volaba las
cometas desde su casa el confinamiento
estimulo en todo brasil una verdadera
fiebre de las cometas la principal
compañía de electricidad del país
detectó un aumento del 200 5% de
incidentes de estos juguetes voladores
en el tendido eléctrico
en favelas como ésta las cometas incluso
representan una importante fuente de
ingresos para capear la crisis causada
por el cob y yo llegué a vender cometas
el hilo a esto me ayudó financieramente
conseguir ganar unos 1100 dólares por
mes vendiendo este material las cometas
remiten a una época en que las clases
más populares podían divertirse con poco
dinero hoy una cometa de papel
a unos pocos céntimos de dólar
pero ahora una peculiaridad en brasil es
que las cometas son de combate el
espíritu es lúdico pero al mismo tiempo
muy competitivo la gracia es cortar el
hilo del adversario cuando cortas 123
cometas es muy emocionante es como si
fuese un campeonato un partido de fútbol
cortar una cometa es lo mismo que meter
uno de hecho existen federaciones que
están luchando para convertir el vuelo
de cometas en un deporte oficial e
incluso con proyección internacional
mucha gente aquí envío es pura
campeonatos fuera de brasil
banchile a francia en campo grande el
barrio más populoso de río de janeiro
visitamos la tienda de luciano hace 20
años convirtió su afición en un negocio
familiar hoy luciano produce 5 mil
cometas por semana junto a su esposa ya
sus hijos
comenzamos a vender cometas cuando
éramos novios al principio los vendíamos
para poder comprar los muebles y
casarnos nos casamos y seguimos
vendiendo las hasta hoy
en todo el proceso de fabricación
intervienen hasta seis profesionales
para producir los distintos componentes
de la cometa
es un procedimiento artesanal que
requiere habilidad y paciencia hoy soy
un profesional de la cometa
en otras palabras consigo ganar dinero y
financiar mi vida a través de una pasión
que es la cometa
luciano es muy popular entre los
aficionados a las cometas
recientemente la práctica de las cometas
ha sido criminalizada la razón el uso
del hilo curado reforzado con vidrio
triturado para potenciar su capacidad
cortante el hilo curado ya causó la
muerte de algún motociclista y la
amputación de las dos piernas de una
niña en río de janeiro por eso fue
prohibido el vuelo de cometas en barrios
residenciales y cerca de las autopistas
a finales de 2019 fue aprobado una ley
en el estado de río que pretende
legalizar los llamados hipódromos es
decir espacios al aire libre como éste
fue creado fue creado para dar seguridad
para poder volar nuestras cometas
entonces nos vamos a lugares aislados
para no perder nadie además existe un
proyecto de ley federal a la espera de
la aprobación del senado
el objetivo es reglamentar la práctica
de este deporte en espacios homologados
más allá de las polémicas las cometas
también pueden ser sinónimo de arte sol
para volar una cometa artística es como
intentar tocar el cielo con las puntas
de los dedos es una cosa más sensitiva
max fabrica estas joyas de papel desde
que era niño ya recorrió muchos países
para presentar sus creaciones en
festivales internacionales
hasta que sólo para hacer esta cabeza
trabajamos 6 días
el cuerpo del dragón ya tarde 14 días
tiene 50 metros de largo un pimiento
el arte eleva el espíritu pero es en la
competición donde los aficionados a las
cometas alcanzan la gloria
vengan todos aquí por favor
carlos magno lucha desde hace años para
profesionalizar las competiciones y el
brujo ha conseguido el apoyo de
políticos locales que aprovechan ese
evento para hacer campaña para las
elecciones municipales tenemos
candidatos en prácticamente todas las
ciudades para tener una persona que
peleé por locales de competición
lucia no se presenta como el candidato
de las cometas las cometas nunca
tuvieron un defensor en los últimos años
están siendo muy discriminadas hoy
dependemos de un parlamentario que esté
luchando y defendiendo esta actividad en
el torneo reencontramos a diego que
comparte equipo con este político el 15
de noviembre luciano conquistó un escaño
en la cámara municipal de río
somos una familia esto no es un grupo
cerrado de amigos somos como hermanos
nuestro tipo no recibe nada solo
queremos volar nuestras cometas durante
varios fines de semana
64 equipos se enfrentan en esta finca en
las afueras de río de janeiro para ganar
no sólo ese trofeo sino también el
derecho a practicar uno de los deportes
más populares de brasil con la alegría
de unos niños pequeños